46 progresistas encontrado 76
abstenciones
consecuencia
por el momento pedro castillo no correrá
la misma suerte que el pedro pablo
kuczynski y martín vizcarra por quinta
vez en los últimos cuatro años el
parlamento debatió la apertura de un
proceso conducente a la institución en
los casos de kuczynski vizcarra esa vía
prosperó y sus mandatos terminaron antes
de tiempo para estudiar el desafuero del
líder populista faltaron 6 de los 52
votos necesarios que iniciativa ha
partido de fuerzas de derecha y
ultraderecha que acusaban a castillo de
haber permitido presiones para ascender
a militares afines la decisión desató
choques de manifestantes en las calles
de lima
terrorista que está en el gobierno con
todo de su popular están logrando
billete corrupto que está destruyendo el
perú
así
[Aplausos]
con un congreso fragmentado la
perspectiva de un nuevo juicio político
nunca está del todo eliminada en perú